[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to the first dope tech
episode in a little while but i'm glad
it's back so the last one was actually
on this crazy high-end ridiculous piece
of video gear the camera robots this one
is also returning to another insane
really high-end piece of video gear
this
this is the venus optics laowa
macro
probe blends
and as you can tell it's
super worthy of the name so i've
actually had this lens for a couple
weeks now started messing with it it's
definitely not the type of lens that you
use very often it's super specialty but
it's already responsible for one
absolutely crazy shot in the last video
the oneplus 7 pro review definitely
check it out if you haven't already i'll
go ahead and drop a link below that like
button okay hold up let's let's rewind
for a second so the company venus optics
makes a bunch of other weird specialty
lenses like this one this super ultra
wide tilt shift macro lens that i've
used for a couple videos especially car
ones
but
why did this one
specifically
i mean it probably would catch your eye
too but why this one why the probe well
you might be like me and you might have
seen a couple clips of this lens
floating around the internet there's
even one really well done viral video of
someone literally shooting this lens
through various subjects and getting all
these crazy shots and then most recently
it appeared in this behind the scenes
video on twitter from phil esposito of
the verge as the critical tool for
getting that crazy intro shot from their
galaxy fold review
once i saw that that sort of piqued my
curiosity i looked it up turns out it
was on b h with like expedited shipping
um
and that was sort of all i needed to see
so within a couple days it was here at
the studio so what's the deal if you're
a video shooter or creator or youtuber
or anything why on earth would you want
a crazy lens like this uh if you think
about it this is a lens that's made
specifically for video
and it's kind of all in the name the
probe lens and there are a lot of crazy
things about this lens so this is what a
normal camera lens looks like you've
probably seen one before this is what a
cine lens looks like made specifically
for video
and this is the pro blends it looks
pretty wild it's about almost a foot and
a half long just a few centimeters wide
for most of the barrel
and the specs it's full frame fully
manual 24 millimeter macro lens f14 to
f40 f14
to f40 what yeah no that's weird let's
break this down so first of all the fact
that it covers full frame is pretty
amazing it's a fully manual lens which
means the aperture ring and the focus
ring are both d-clicked and fully hand
operated instead of electronic there
also happens to be seven aperture blades
by the way and 27 different optical
elements in the whole tube and it's a
macro lens meaning the minimum focus
distance is really close one and a half
feet but when you measure minimum focus
distance from the flange or from the
sensor basically
that one and a half feet puts it just
inches away from the end of the barrel
of the lens which is also pretty crazy
and then the 24 millimeters is also odd
most macro lenses are around 100
millimeters in focal length which is
great that gets you really close to the
subject but also really isolates it with
the super shallow depth of field a 24
millimeter macro it still lets you get
super close but it keeps this wide angle
field of view and more is in focus and
then the f14 to f40 is kind of a
blessing and a curse on one hand if you
could go all the way wide open to f 2.8
or f4 or something you'd probably get
almost nothing in focus so it kind of
saves you from that
but on the other hand at f14 wide open
it means you need a lot of light for
this lens like a lot of light and then
keeping up with the probe theme the
front end of this lens is actually
waterproof so you can not only probe you
know small spaces but you can submerge
it even get underwater shots if you want
to and then you can see up front there's
actually this ring of that is right leds
because this lens has lights built in to
the lens it's a lot so if you're
shooting in a very small space or a dark
space you can use the light to
illuminate your subject there's
literally a micro usb port on the barrel
of this lens that plugs into it and it
comes with a micro usb cable in the box
so if you attach it to some sort of
power brick like i did and then plug it
in and turn it on
you end up with this uh
sort of a magic wand of an experience
it's pretty bright too that's all the
leds lit up at once a ring light at the
end of your probe lens it's crazy but of
course when it all comes down to it of
course the shape of this lens is what
makes it such a unique tool obviously
being so narrow you can get right up
like super close to things you can be in
small spaces and then of course you're
sort of really close to something while
being far away from it at the same time
and there's also a bunch of youtube
videos detailing a bunch of examples of
this even that viral video depicting
kind of shooting it the shooting part is
fake there's nothing detaching from the
lens here that's definitely edited but
the shots it got that they included
those shots are actually real and
they're super well done and there's so
many other good ones so that of course
got the gears turning about how to
possibly use the probe lens for a tech
video or a shot in a tech video or just
to shoot tech
in some way and of course we saw phil's
video with the galaxy fold so the story
goes as you know i got the oneplus 7 pro
a couple weeks beforehand and had this
lens in hand the entire time so uh i
knew i had to try something so of course
to maximize how dramatic it is you want
to get as close to the phone as possible
and like i said even at f14 wide open
you need a ton of light to get even see
anything usable even in broad daylight
or super strong studio lights you got to
crank the iso at f14 the thing is
phone screens
are actually really not that bright and
if you shine lights at them they get
less bright so turns out that's actually
why the verges video was shot in this
dark setting with a dark background
because it's the only way to really see
the phone's display with this lens so
that's why i ended up having to do
basically the same thing for the oneplus
7 pro phone screens just aren't bright
enough to compete against other lights
so the only way to really see it vividly
is to turn the rest of the lights off
kind of like how your phone screen looks
the brightest at night but we had some
other practicals and some other lights
in the scene and then even after we set
everything up with a shot like this the
work isn't done until a little bit of
coloring a little bit of editing to
brighten up the phone denoising effects
adding and potentially even sound design
etc but the final shot is so worth it so
really as it's turning out the best way
to maximize this lens when shooting
objects with it is number one to get
really really close to your subject
usually a small subject and then you
know play with movement a bit and
specifically things around the barrel to
really get that perspective that it
creates of being like a tiny person on
like a small surface with things going
past you
so that's what we tried to do so here
are some other examples of some shots
we've done
with the probe lens
alright so this was a fun one yes in the
studio we do have cd racks that have
never held a cd in their life instead
they hold the smartphones
don't worry it's perfect so i was
literally just wondering what it would
look like to move through the phones as
if you were like a bug flying through
them so the red is on a slider we
pointed lights at it like lots of lights
and there's almost no other point to
this shot other than really just seeing
how cool it would look from that crazy
inside perspective we did a couple
different versions you know pull versus
push moves but other than that there's
no subject in the middle we literally
just got the shot to see if you could
get it and you couldn't with any other
traditional lens even a gopro wouldn't
fit in the opening this lens is fitting
through
all right so this one's just fun and i
think a lot of that's just because it's
really colorful and i was hungry but i
think it would be even more awesome with
maybe the robot or with possibly a true
slow-motion camera like a phantom or
something crazy but the setup is similar
it's got a lot of light and then just
timing the m ms falling over and
spilling basically over the lens and
that was the challenge is to time it
right so this was shot in slow motion
the red does handle 120 fps at 4k so
that was not a problem
but we had plenty of other versions and
other bloopers with this shot with the m
ms spilling everywhere and weird timing
because it's human error you know you're
not going to get it perfect every time
but the final version it couldn't have
worked out any better with the m ms
bouncing pretty much right over the lens
just like a transition
[Music]
[Music]
all right shout out to andy so this one
actually is inspired by that viral video
where it looks like it goes through this
brush with all the bristles um this one
just fake plants so for this one i was
thinking we were gonna use the light on
the front of the lens for this one but
after a few test shots it turned out to
definitely still be too harsh like a
spotlight so we turned that off and
basically doubled down on lighting the
environment a lot better so there's
still a ton of light here and the
original shot was actually pulling the
move on the slider backwards so the fake
grass would sort of naturally move over
to cover up the lens as it goes past so
the final shot you see is just playing
it back reversed
and then the lighting on the android at
the end as it dims out that was just
timed by hand just by moving the light i
was holding 100 practical effects 100
probe lens
so this was a horizontal slide of course
as you could tell similar lighting setup
to the last one but just moving the
lights higher up so they didn't glare
off this matte black keyboard so much
and then you can actually see the rgb
lights better i'm actually honestly
surprised these showed up on video so
well and then just getting super close
to the keyboard kind of like you really
couldn't with any other lens
so that was a fun one the perspective we
imagined when we were dreaming up this
shot is like the zipper sort of opening
past you like you're this tiny like a
bug again and this giant zipper is sort
of chasing you away the tough part is
obviously since the depth of field is so
shallow it's super easy to go in or out
of focus if the timing which is by hand
isn't absolutely perfect so there's
plenty of takes of that where my hand
goes in and out of focus so i didn't
worry about that too much instead the
more interesting part is making it feel
like the zipper is closing around you
and being so low to the ground like only
the probe lens can definitely helped
with that
[Music]
so this is the last and i'll say the
most difficult one just because it's
entirely handheld and free-flowing and
it is not a lightweight camera but the
perspective is basically as if you're
you know attached to the marker like
you're a bug holding onto the marker for
dear life as i write something and uh it
kind of turned out pretty well and you
could probably do this with another 24
millimeter lens if the minimum focus
distance was close enough but you know
that was fun to shoot anyway but yeah
that is the probe lens it's clearly not
a conventional lens and there's almost
no reason to actually go get one you
kind of have to invent ways to use it
but those couple times where you do
actually find a good use for it and it
turns out to work really well
it's so worth it so that that's what
makes this dope tech so of course now
that you've seen it on video you'll be
the first to recognize it when you see a
shot occasionally from it in a future
video kind of like the robot shots you
guys recognize i promise not to overuse
it but i'm super glad we have it thanks
for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
you